I'll tell you a little story.
This is in my book,
so I had this landlord in Montreal.
He lived next door to me and he was an
ex hell's angels biker.
He'd spent a lot of time in prison and
his wife had borderline personality
disorder and she committed suicide when
I lived there and was a rough guy and he
was at Caa Quebec law and he spoke to
you all,
which I could hardly understand.
And uh,
he didn't really know what to make of me
and I didn't really know what to make of
him,
but we got along,
you know,
and I was very careful talking to him
as,
as you might imagine,
but,
but I,
I was,
it was very.
And we went over to my wife and I went
over there and we had a spaghetti dinner
one night and we sort of communicated
and I bought a poster from him because
he made these wooden posters that had
neon on them.
And that's how we made a living.
He'd Kinda trained himself to be a bit
of an electronics guy.
And so we made these things and he was
trying to quit drinking and we talked
about that.
He was a lot older than me.
He was like 20 years older than me.
I was about 25 at this point.
And uh,
we got along pretty well.
But every now and then he'd go out and
get a drink and he could really drink,
you know,
like he was one of these guys who could
drink like 60 beer and you think,
well no one can drink that much and
you're wrong.
I studied alcohol for like 10 years,
some of my subjects,
father's drank 40 ounces of vodka a day
and had been doing it for 20 years so
you can drink a lot and he could drink a
lot.
And what would happen?
He was trying to,
not drink,
but he'd go out and go on a binge and
then he'd be gone for like three days
and he drink up all his money.
And then we'd hear him out in the
backyard howling at the moon with this
little little ugly dog he had,
you know,
and he'd hold him,
the dog would hell.
And he'd haul them and the dog would
haul and,
and it was a rather unsettling and made
my wife nervous and what worse,
you know now,
and then he'd come to the door like
three in the morning,
hey,
and he'd knock on the door and he'd be
standing there and I don't know how much
experience you've had with rough guys
who are alcoholic and who are drunk,
but it's,
they can be upright and unconscious at
the same time.
And so that was the state that he was
in,
you know,
he'd be just swaying and he'd asked me
if I would like to buy his toaster or
his microwave because he needed some
money to keep drinking.
And you know,
I didn't really want to buy his toaster
or as microwave.
But when the x hell's angel,
you all speaking 60 beard,
drunk Quebecois biker shows up at your
door at three in the morning.
And the offers you to sell offers to
sell you his microwave.
The easiest thing is to say I really
need a microwave.
So,
so you know,
I bought the microwave and toaster and
some other things.
But then,
but then my wife talked to me and she
liked my landlord,
you know,
even though she was afraid of him,
she liked him and she said,
you can't buy any more,
any more appliances because it's not
good for him.
And I thought,
Huh,
that's an interesting problem.
So what the hell am I going to do about
this because no,
I don't want to buy your microwave just
doesn't seem to be the right answer at
three in the morning.
So.
So one time he took me out on his 7:50
Honda and he put me on the back of it.
He wanted to show me his layer,
I guess his hangouts and I got his
wife's helmet on but it didn't fit it
just sit on the top of my head and he
said,
I go to the bike and he said if the cops
chase us,
we're not stopping.
And then away we went and we went to
these,
like these bars downtown on south of the
road.
They were very rough places and he got
into like four fights that night because
he was a rough guy,
you know.
And these kind of punk guys would come
up to them and sort of challenge them
and act stupidly around him and he was
very skeptical and if you were acting
stupidly around him for any length of
time,
he just hit you because he felt that
that's what you deserved.
And perhaps he was right,
you know,
so.
So I had a firsthand opportunity to
observe him.
So anyways,
he sure enough,
about a week or two after we had this
conversation,
he showed up at the door,
knock,
you know,
opened the door and they're standing
there with his eyes half closed and he
was swaying and he had,
I don't remember what the appliance was
this time,
but he wanted to sell it to me and I
said,
I'm not all I can buy this.
I'm not going to buy this because I know
you're trying to quit drinking.
And if I give you this money then you're
going to go and drink it up and it's not
going to be good for you.
And what else did I tell him?
I think I told him as well that this
whole thing of him coming to my house at
like two in the morning was scaring my
wife who we liked and that it had to
stop and believe me,
man.
I was thinking about what I was saying
because he was watching me like a rough
guy watches you and a rough guy watches
you like this.
He thinks if you say one thing that
indicates contempt,
you're going to bloody well pay for it.
And so I was finding my words like,
you know,
I was crossing a swamp and trying to
look for the,
for the rocks underneath the surface.
And I said what I had to say very,
very carefully.
And he looked at me for about 15 seconds
and that's a long time to be looked at
at three in the morning.
And he left and he never came back to
sell me anything again.
And we got along fine.
But that's a good illustration of this
issue with regards to truth and success
in the strange land.
Because I was in the strange land when I
was talking to my neighbor,
my landlord Dan and I managed to say
what was true carefully enough so
despite the fact that he was a very
violent person and that he was very
intoxicated person and then he had every
reason to be suspicious of me and we
couldn't communicate very well and I
didn't do what he wanted,
that he took it and he left and there
was no problem and life went on just
fine after that,
and so we don't want to underestimate
the utility of establishing this bounded
relationship with the ideal and
attempting to live with some nobility in
truth while aiming at the highest ideal.
There's nothing about that.
That's anything but strengthening and
positive and it's exactly what you need
to set against the catastrophe and
uncertainty of life.